[Musique]
on voit ça que dans les films et en vrai
c'est pas pareil
[Musique]
je m'appelle à lionel j'ai 42 ans j'ai
travaillé pour hélène pendant ces mois
le 22 mars 2017 je suis arrivé sur mon
lieu de travail a
comme d'habitude pour 8 heures
[Musique]
fou
j'ai vu
le meurtrier
corriera derrière la maison
il avait mis à terre et
les chats l'époque qu'il avait un
couteau
[Musique]
moi
souvent les femmes victimes de violence
conjugale aux victimes de faits
m'initier danse les imagine comme on
peut les voir sur les affiches de
prévention et une femme de 40 50 ans
sur les images elles sont souvent
représentés marqué avec des bleus sur le
visage des pelé avec ce slogan une femme
meurt tous les trois jours sous les
coups de son conjoint et c'est vrai
qu'elle end et monte un peu tous les
clichés qu'on peut avoir des femmes
victimes de violence conjugale est
victime de féminicide
[Musique]
je m'appelle anne-sophie j'ai 30 ans et
je suis la petite soeur d'hélène
[Musique]
je suis issue d'une fratrie de trois
filles donc hélène ma soeur aînée donc
moi en deuxième et céline la petite
dernière on a toujours été très uni
toutes les trois on est vraiment une
fratrie qui a toujours été très
complices depuis notre enfance on a eu
cette chance
[Musique]
c'est là que vous avez commencé le poney
tout soit pas longtemps
ça rappelle plein de souvenirs l'autre
la
[Musique]
voile à une jeune femme blonde sur un
cheval alezan c'est à dire vous passe
exactement comme même ma grande hélène
hélène avait une grande passion depuis
tout petit depuis l'âge de 5 ans et l
équitation
[Musique]
passion que je vous ai transmises
puisque j'ai toujours venu avec moi au
centre équestre moi même je pratique
l'équitation donc on y aller ensemble et
dès l'âge de 5 ans elle a voulu monter à
poney et ça ne l'a jamais quitté
[Musique]
oh
hélène était bon une petite île adorable
facile à élever
adolescente comme tous les ados parfois
un petit peu regardants crise avec avec
ses parents et avec sa maman et
heureusement on avait ce point commun
l'équitation cette passion commune ça
nous a tous rapprochés et ça nous a
aidés à passer les câbles de la crise de
tous les sens
hélène avait beaucoup de caractère elle
se laissait pas faire c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'elle s'est mise à son compte
elle a passé son monitorat d'équitation
elle a commencé par être salarié dans un
centre équestre mais en fait elle s'est
rapidement rendu compte qu'elle avait
du mal à avoir un supérieur au dessus
d'elle et
elle avait du mal à ce qu'on lui dise
quoi faire et c'est pour ça qu'elle
s'est rapidement mise à son compte
[Musique]
on fait comment pour avancer vous savez
ça
s'écoute à lure très bien et on se
penche
[Musique]
c'est ilan qui m'a demandé un jour on
revenait trop court épique qui m'a
demandé maman est ce que ça te dirait qu
on comprenne un centre équestre toutes
les deux et ben moi c'était un petit
rêve aussi enfouie depuis longtemps et
que ma fille me propose de faire ça avec
moi c'était génial pas donc donc on a
mûri le projet et puis effectivement
d'en racheter un petit club côté de rien
sans la campagne toujours
[Musique]
très bien c'est plus grand que ça a de
la force qui a toujours besoin de la
nature est la première séance j'apprends
voit tout de suite il y en a qui sont à
l'aise tout de suite d'autres il ya
besoin de les accompagner un petit peu
plus longtemps
ilan était très gentille c'était un
choix de patronne timide un peu au début
mais après ça les salles et murs
j'avais dit à hélène et
il ya un moment
dans quatre ans ça va faire 30 ans que
je travaille dans ce sens rennes-brest
j'espère qu'on sera tous ensemble
[Musique]
elle avait sa maison juste à côté du
centre équestre nous vraiment dans la
forêt en fait avec aucun voisin et salah
dérangez absolument pas elle n'avait
jamais peur elle dormait
tous ces volets ouverts pas vraiment
alors qu'elle vivait seule dans sa forêt
alors je lui ai jamais à la tâche a park
l'hiver a été frileuse donc à la veille
de jours froids je rigolais toujours
avec heidi et tu pourras au pôle nord
[Musique]
il a été en couple pendant trois ans
elle était vraiment
très très amoureuse très rapidement
après galera à quai les rencontrer et
l'imaginé vraiment comme l'homme de sa
vie c'était sa grande histoire d'amour
elle nous en parlait toujours avec avec
les yeux qui brillaient on allait le
voir
au magasin où il travaillé et on avait
elle trouvait toujours une excuse pour
le croiser discuter avec
[Musique]
et c'est lui qui a été à l'initiative de
la rupture qu elle n a très très mal
vécu en plus c'était assez soudain
aiment s'y attendait pas et ça a été
vraiment très très difficile pour elle
[Musique]
elle a
beaucoup de mal à s'en remettre je pense
qu'elle s'en est même le jamais vraiment
remis
elle était vulnérable
fragile à ce moment là
et même dans son cercle d'amis je pense
que inconsciemment on l'a on l'a poussé
à rencontrer d'autres personnes et a
retrouvé sa joie de vivre
[Musique]
quelques semaines après elle a rencontré
yannick dans le cadre professionnel
elle était monitrice d'équitation dans
les ardennes
[Musique]
et lui étaient clients du centre
équestre donc c'est comme ça qu'ils se
sont rencontrés
elle s'entendait bien avec lui c'est un
des clients sympa du centre équestre
avec qui
elle buvait un coup de temps en temps
avec d'autres clients
et cetera
elle nous a expliqué que ça faisait
plusieurs mois qu'effectivement il eut
tourné autour qu'il l'appréciait qu'il
avait déjà invité plusieurs fois elle
nous en a parlé assez rapidement mais en
tant que
copains enfin vraiment sans plus au
début
ils venaient tous les buts n ont discuté
moi c'était quelqu'un de gentil que même
un jour je tombé en panne de scooter il
m'a précédé son vélo pour rentrer chez
moi
le temps que je vais perdre mon scooter
moi je l'avais rencontré plusieurs fois
lors des concours hippiques ou au club
quand y avait un anniversaire quelque
chose il était pompier bénévole cet
homme là le bon c'était quelqu'un qui
passe et sympathique avait de l'humour
qui mettait de l'ambiance qui faisait
rire tout le monde
c'était plutôt voilà monsieur tout le
monde plutôt agréable
il a bien vu ma fille en grande détresse
et bien voilà je pense qu'il était
attiré par cette jeune monitrice le
grande jeune femme blonde
[Musique]
yannick a insisté pendant plusieurs mois
plusieurs semaines avant qu elle n
accepte de d'être intime avec lui
[Musique]
yannick c'était quelqu'un qui est déjà
beaucoup plus âgé qu'elle est n'est
physiquement pas
gracieux par
c'était pas un beau mec
pas du tout
c'est
je sais même pas ce qu'il vit à trier
c'est l'opposé d'hélène au début de la
relation hélène on sentit que voilà il
lui apporter quelque chose de positif
dans le sens où elle avait retrouvé le
sourire il était drôle
[Musique]
elle aime ce qu'elle me disait c'est que
elle était contente de le voir le
week-end que ça l'arrangé il faisait
leurs affaires et la semaine avait été
tranquille mais c'est tout ça s'arrêtait
là elle ne se projetait pas du tout avec
j'avais les psys les experts ne crois
jamais au hasard en quelque sorte un
donc elle était
fragilisée par une rupture douloureuse
lui était en recherche en appétence
comme ça d'une d'une jeune femme
beaucoup plus jeune que lui d'ailleurs
il le dit le d'yves la crise de la
quarantaine fin oui il le dit très
explicitement donc il ya cette rencontre
l'an hélène était mon ami quoi qu'il
arrive donc je vais accepter ses choix
mais mais elle savait que j'étais pas
particulièrement fan de l'idée qu'elles
soient en couple avec quelqu'un de plus
âgé quelqu'un qui avait un enfant et qui
avait voilà déjà été mariée
en plus en plus voilà j'en avais on
avait parlé de certaines choses yannick
voilà je savais très bien qu'il est mais
qu'il aimait les femmes
on était au courant qu'il avait trompé
son ex femme et que voilà je voulais pas
qu'elle souffre davantage
hélène avait besoin d'une épaule en plus
une épaule
rassurante ce qu'était yannick durand
jamais l'oublier
[Musique]
je m'appelle monique derrien je suis
journaliste depuis plus de trente ans
j'ai découvert beaucoup de grands procès
la chronique judiciaire a très vite et
est ma spécialité
yannick durand quand on le voit on n'a
pas forcément de raison de s'inquiéter
il parle avec une belle voix très
apaisante
pas du tout inquiétante pour moi ces
lieux souvenir que j'ai de cet homme
c'est c'est quelqu'un dont on ne peut
pas penser qu'il a été capable de donner
un coup de couteau à une jeune femme
[Musique]
se sont mis ensemble en décembre 2013 il
me semble
et au fur et à mesure des mois ça c'est
un petit peu dégradée parce que il avait
un côté un côté agressif quelle qu'elle
ne connaissait pas et qu'elle a
découvert lors de soirées à soirée chez
les pompiers par exemple ou quand il
buvait de l'alcool il avait tendance à
devenir violent pas forcément envers
elle mais dans ses paroles où elle
sentait que sa personnalité était
vraiment différente
et donc une soirée peut-être un an en
avril après après leur rencontre un soir
ils étaient ensemble chez lui il a
commencé à prendre pleins pleins vider
les poches de médicaments donc
évidemment hélène essayé de l'empêcher
mais
il était de toute façon plus fort que
qu'elle donc lui continué la seule chose
dont je me souviens très bien ce qu elle
n a eu très très peur parce qu'il a pris
un couteau et qu'il l'a fait les fait
mine de se trancher la gorge devant elle
il s'est mis ces coupes et là sans la
gorge en la regardant droit dans les
yeux
[Musique]
dans les profils d'auteur de féminicide
assez souvent si vous voulez il ya ce
qu'on appelle le chantage au suicide ce
soir là elle venait pas du tout pour
l'équité donc c'était même pas en
situation de rupture mais je pense que
même si après elle avait voulu le
quitter mais à chaque fois il y penser
avant je me remettrai jamais de ça donc
il la tenait sans le dire avec des mots
mais c'est sa l'emprise de toute façon
le lardin tout l'art du manipulateur et
de la personne qui exerce une emprise
sur l'autre c'est justement l'autre ne
s'en aperçoit absolument pas monsieur
durand n'avait aucune personnalité
suicides est assez dépressive absolument
pas donc si ici mais ça en avant par
rapport à hélène cannes c'est simplement
pour la culpabiliser si vous voulez je
peux pas dire qu'il ya eu des signes
avant coureurs il ya eu des difficultés
mais l'ex compagne ne relate pas de
faits de violence
yannick durand est quelqu'un de tout à
fait normal quelqu'un vous pouvez
croiser dans la rue monsieur monsieur
tout le monde si je puis dire
la quarantaine un peu passer quelqu'un
d'insérer
il a fait un de manière assez assez
théâtrale à s'il avait réellement voulu
se suicider il aurait pas
ah ils l'auraient pas fait de cette
manière
[Musique]
ah oui en fait non mais non en fait en
fait pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout mais en fait quelques mois
après la naissance de l'enfant le couple
a connu des difficultés qu'il s'adonnait
à l'alcool perdez sur l'emploi et ses
deux tentatives de suicide qui avait
provoqué son hospitalisation
en psy c'est pas tout à fait je me
souvenais pas de sens je vais le
reprendre
donc le coup d'avant c'était oui je sais
quoi je pense que c'était une autre
femme qui l'avait qu'il avait rencontré
qui avait indiqué qu'il n'était pas
violent
après
cet épisode de tentative de suicide il
était un hôpital psychiatrique jeu pour
prendre une semaine et là on avait dit
allen et coûteux voilà et celle de
prendre de la distance
il faut que ça soit il a été pris en
charge médicalement
et elle nous a pas écoutés elle y est
allée elle y est allée loire peut-être
même tous les soirs elle lui a porté des
vêtements des livres
voilà elle était aux petits soins pour
lui c'est effectivement en partie en
tous les cas elle est la conséquence du
mécanisme de dépersonnalisation
[Musique]
je n'ai plus mes repères
familiaux professionnels amicaux etc je
suis complètement
dépendantes ou sous l'emprise de l'autre
en fait et donc je ne vois plus que par
lui je ne peut plus penser que par lui
je voyais bien qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui n'allait pas que c'est pas une
relation saine
et oui j'ai essayé d'en parler avec
hélène alors c'est délicat parce que bon
c'était quand même son compagnon dans
mon souvenir elle était souvent sur la
défensive
ne voulais pas forcément parler où
c'était plus un problème qu'elle voulait
occulté donc on a vu des fous et ça a
été gelé à cause de de plusieurs
échanges parfois pas forcément facile
avec mes filles
[Musique]
je me souviens lui avoir dit qu'il
fallait absolument qu'elle le quitte et
qu elle ne revoit jamais
[Musique]
elle s'est fâchée
ça lui a pas plu du tout elle m'a dit
que je me trompe et à
qu'elle l'aimait
l'emprise est aussi et est alimentée
dans un couple entend la sexualité
monsieur durand sur sa sexualité quand
on lui en parle il ya une poussée
narcissique très important les bien
qu'on parle de ça c'est manifestement et
puis il va me parler de ses conquêtes
etc
[Musique]
je pense qu'elle a dû lui trouver un
intérêt certainement important
ça a dû d'ailleurs chez elle faire un
débat intérieur on éviterait importance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a senti un danger on a commencé à
avoir peur pour elle que ça soit moi que
ça soit ces autres ses autres amis
proches sa maman ses soeurs on a
vraiment commencé à sentir quelque chose
de malsain
et la seule manière qu'on a eus
d'essayer de protéger hélène c'était
peut-être pas la meilleure des façons
mais on a voulu éloigner yannick denaud
de vie de nos vies
à partir du moment où effectivement mon
environnement familial dit il faut plus
voir etc et c'est un type qui est
dangereux enfin etc etc ils se moquent
de toi qu'est-ce que tu es devenu etc
manifestement c'est un effet inverse 1
c'est à dire que ce mécanisme cela
va alimenter chez elle le fait de
protéger monsieur monsieur durand et
après voilà les relations ont changé moi
lui après c'était plus distants il ya
plus les soirées festives où tout le
monde rigolait sayah plus
où ils ne venaient plus après voilà ils
venaient plus repas de famille tout ça
ils venaient plus je pense que parce
qu'il est loin d'être bête donc il a dû
comprendre qu'on ferait peut-être tout
pour qu'elle ne puisse
se sortir de cette relation qui ne nous
paraissait pas saine
[Musique]
la famille n'aimait pas monsieur durand
parce qu'il était plus vieux que la
victime parce qu'on l'aimé pas parce
qu'on trouvait qu'il était comme ça
comme ça enfin bref plein de raisons qui
sont peut-être valable d'ailleurs mais
bon on n'aime pas donc il se dit le
poids de la famille créé la rupture
donc c'est pas son choix c'est pas le
choix de ma compagne de me laisser c'est
la pression de sa famille donc il
comprend pas c'est durant il se dit mais
pourquoi elle rompt si elle même encore
parce qu'ils la pression de sa famille
et où elle a un mec alors il essaie de
voir s'il a un copain
à partir de février 2016 je suis devenu
jaloux
cliniquement si vous voulez monsieur
durand pour employer une expression
comme ça c'est quelqu'un qu'on ne quitte
pas
c'est vraiment la prise dans toute sa
splendeur c'est à dire que il finissait
par être là à chaque instant on pas la
lâcher oh c'est allé très loin
hélène s'est rendu compte que yannick la
suivait
elle a vu sa voiture plusieurs fois
il avait mis en place même une routine
et là nous l'avait expliqué voilà qui
faisait le tour du centre et qu'est-ce
qu'ils allaient près de son domicile
et ensuite chez ses amis proches et sa
famille sa maman notamment
[Musique]
quand il a une idée en tête il n'a pas
ailleurs il a des idées fixes donc là
son idée fixe ct elle
le lundi 6 je suis revenue la voir nous
avons dîné ensemble j'ai dormi chez elle
ils essayent de la récupérer et ça
marche donc il se dit en essayant de
récupérer en étant jalloud les en
afrique et où arrive aux endroits où
elle est ça remarche puisque je reviens
avec c'est un concours de circonstance
en fait vous avez quelqu'un qui ne
supporte pas la séparation et enfin si
une femme qui sépareront
elle avait envie de le quitter ça a duré
pendant plus d'un an vraiment elle avait
plus envie de cette situation là elle a
vraiment essayé de mettre de la distance
entre eux pour qu'ils comprennent et
qu'ils se lassent et finissent par la
quitter
est ce qui a fini par arriver du coup
début 2017
vous allez récupérer mes dernières
affaires personnelles on était toujours
en train de s'engueuler pour un rien et
là nous avons décidé d'arrêter
où
[Musique]
et le lendemain en arrivant au centre
équestre au début d'après midi hélène
est venu me voir tout de suite et m'a
dit tu sais pas ce qu'il m'arrive ça y
est il m'a quitté ça y est c'est fini et
du coup la première chose c'est bon on
va fêter ça on va boire un coup
et finalement le sediba il m'a quitté
c'est lui qui a pris la décision donc
j'ai plus rien à craindre
elle était heureuse
pour
et finalement après ça c'est là où tout
est
ces lots
[Musique]
où
c'est là où tout et tout a dégénéré
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce
soir là avec hélène où elle devait me
donner un cours à cheval et elle m'a dit
vas finir la soirée on va boire un coup
à la maison on a dû remonter vers 22
heures chez elle et moi je suis partie à
2 heures du matin donc pendant quatre
heures on a discuté on a parlé de tout
de rien
et quand je suis parti à peine le moteur
des marais
hélène m'a raconté que yannick est sorti
deux sous le lit
[Musique]
il était dans la chambre d'amis dans sa
maison et il nous a écouté pendant des
heures caché sous le lit
[Musique]
quand hélène l'a raconté le lendemain
déjà quand je suis arrivée elle m'a
sauté dessus pour me le dire il m'a pris
mon portable il voulait pas que je
puisse l'utiliser il est énervé
il pense que j'ai une relation
c'est un film d'horreur
c'est ça
dès le lendemain ou le surlendemain il a
commencé à renvoyer des messages enfin
il va pas lâcher tout de suite il
l'appeler il voulait garder un contact
téléphonique il voulait pas qu'il avait
du mal à supporter que ça s'arrête
complètement moi je vais demander
souvent ça va ce qui t'a appelé
aujourd'hui est ce qui te laisse
tranquille donc certains jours pendant
deux trois jours il y avait plus
d'appels dont conseillers où on était
content qu'ils aient ça y est cette fois
il a lâché la faire et puis non ça
recommençait en matière criminelle j'en
ai vu quelques-uns comme ça et c'est
tout à fait redoutable à partir du
moment où ils ont ce ce sentiment voire
plus que ça cette conviction que l'autre
va leur échapper à ce moment là ils
deviennent implacable dans la violence
exercée
oh
il devait être autour de minuit elle
était dans son salon en train de
regarder la télé sur son téléphone et
il a pris une pierre il a cassé la vitre
de son salon et il est entré
il lui a pris son téléphone pour voir si
elle parlait pas avec un autre ou froid
si vous voyez pas quelqu'un d'autre
quand il a vu qu'il y avait rien dans
ses téléphones il lui a rendu
il s'est excusé il a nettoyé les bouts
de verre ils ont discuté un petit peu et
elle a réussi à le faire repartir
donc ça c'était un vendredi soir et moi
j'y allais tous les samedis matin
j'avais au centre équestre et elle m'a
appelé avant que j'arrive en décembre
mais à un moment il s'est encore passé
quelque chose hier soir avec annick à
tout prix me raconter ça et là je lui
dis bon là il est maintenant stop on
peut pas un peu plus supporter ça il
faut appeler il faut aller porter
plainte là c'est grave il y rentrer chez
toi par effraction et à terroriser on
sait pas comment ça aurait pu finir en
fait état ce qui est vrai chez toi
finalement est abritée portables enfin
c'est lourd c'est grave quoi il faut
porter plainte
[Musique]
la sphère hélène cannes c'est un cas
d'école en fait parce que tous les
les ingrédients sont là
du
ratage du ratage de la prévention il ya
eu
des tentatives de plates des plaintes
qui sont toujours restées sans suite un
manque de
prise en compte de la gravité de la
situation
par les gendarmes
comme si souvent le cas
un jour à 1 samedi il y avait une
patronne qui est venu au revoir hélène
et la maman après j'ai essayé de
l'appeler lui envoyer des messages
marc est promue t'inquiète pas il se
passe rien et on m'a dit qu'on voulait
pas me mettre en danger deux mois s'il
n'est pas moi qui partageait pas ce que
c'était
[Musique]
je suis un son du four ancien juge
d'instruction j'ai occupé cette fonction
pendant sept ans
pour l'essai du 3 mars a été décidé un
rappel à la loi avec obligation
d'indemniser les victimes c'est-à-dire
pour rembourser le carreau mais il s'est
rien passé d'autre et sur les deux
gendarmes y en a même un qui s'est
permis de faire de l'humour en disant ah
bah oui les pompiers bénévoles donc il
sait comment comment rentrer dans un
logement sans passer par la porte
ok même si on met même mois se sur le
coup ça m'a même pas choquer je me suis
fait de l'humour je pense qu'on fait
quand on est en plein dedans on se rend
pas compte à quel point c'est grave quoi
est elle entendue effectivement que le
gendarme
n'a pas du tout pris ça au sérieux n'a
pas évaluer la dangerosité du personnage
et la haine elle est ressorti de là elle
pleurait disons mais ils m'ont pas
compris mon pas entendu ils vont rien
faire il va rien se passer quoi
[Musique]
la dernière fois où on a vu hélène
c'était le 17 mars 2017 elle est venue à
la maison pour fêter la saint-patrick
avec des amis et de la famille à nous et
sur les coups de 22 heures
elle m'a glissé son téléphone sur la
table pour que je vois qu'il l'appelait
[Rires]
c'était yannick qui essayé de la joindre
elle se demandait ce qui allait se
passer elle se demandait s'il était en
colère s'il était tout proche de chez
moi et elle nous a demandé de surtout
rien faire de ne surtout pas faire de
mal à yannick de ne pas prendre contact
avec lui et de le laisser tranquille
qu'il allait qu'il allait se lasser et
qu'elle allait pouvoir être tranquille
une fois qu'ils en auraient marre
[Musique]
ce 22 mars il est aux hellènes et partis
de bonne heure pour venir s'occuper de
ses shows et elle ne sait pas qu'il ya
une île durant lé observe depuis des
heures
déjà qu'il est en faction
il s'est posté là pour être sûr de ne
pas la rater
je suis arrivé sur mon lieu de travail a
comme d'habitude pour 8 heures
je descendais tranquillement avec mon
scooter pour le dire et le long des
écuries hélène était en train de nourrir
les chevaux
début j'avais vu une ombre
derrière la voiture d'élèves je pensais
que c'était le chien est il après quand
je descendais tranquillement j'ai vu
yannick
courir au niveau des laines et je
pensais qu'il avait oublié quelque chose
et il peut il avoir discuté avec elle
il ne part pas ils en viennent aux mains
elle tombe par terre j'ai lancé mon
casque amis d'enfance âgés couru
au lait c'est pareil il lui donne deux
coups de couteau dont un mortel j'ai
réussi à les séparer il s'est sauvé
yannick durand tourner les talons avec
ces mots plaçant je t'avais dit que je
t'aurais
hélène était à terre dans mes bras
il ya un moment le disait plus rien et
ça a été fini
le corps sans vie de la jeune femme a
été retrouvée près de 7 records pour
chevaux elle aurait été tuée à l'armé
blanche c'est un employé qui a fait la
macabre découverte une personne a été
interpellée à rethel dans les ardennes
et placée en garde à vue
[Musique]
yannick durand est interpellé très
rapidement puisque donc on a son nom ses
huiles habite donc les oppose pas de
résistance particulière il suit les
gendarmes donc la garde à vue des buts
est devant moi c'est à dire au moment de
la première comparution
il m'explique quand gros
s'ils pouvaient pas la récupérer il est
usuel
ce qui provient donc sa détermination et
sa volonté de prendre l'avis d'hélène
cannes
je le met en examen le 24 mars 2017 et
il est placé en détention provisoire il
le restera jusqu'à son procès
[Musique]
quand je suis arrivée elle m'a dit tu
dégages et là j'ai pas accepté je l' ai
pris par le col elle m'a mis un coup de
gamelles et là j'ai vu rouge
à partir du moment où on lui a dit
dégage pour moi c'est très important à
ce moment là il ya eu une espèce
d'envahissement pulsionnel et il n'a pas
pu contrôler les choses
[Musique]
je compare ça assez souvent au principe
de la cocotte-minute 1 c'est à dire que
l'envahissement pulsionnel c'est
le mot le comportement la posture de la
victime qui va déclencher cette fureur
criminelle chez l'auteur s'immoler
[Musique]
je me souviens de ce procès comme d'une
échéance très attendue parce que le
drame de cette famille avait ému toute
la région et donc la salle était
effectivement très remplie
si elle a fait la une de l'union pendant
trois jours avec sa photo en gros plan
avec son cheval voilà meurtre centre
équestre de trigny avec sa photo
[Musique]
donc j'étais très en colère sur le coup
c'était mon drame privé la mort de ma
fille qui devenait une affaire publique
[Musique]
et en fait on s'est dit puisque puisque
toute façon d'autres histoires assez
devenu un fait public on va en parler on
va médiatiser et puis ça peut sauver
d'autres vies si ça peut les aider des
familles et sauver des femmes ne sera
pas parti pour rien quoi voilà
[Musique]
c'est ma grande soeur qui était depuis
l'année dernière par son ex le message
nous qu'on voulait vraiment faire faire
passer s'étendant contre la parole des
femmes une femme qui vient se plaindre
qui vient porter plainte elle n'y va pas
pour rien si elle se sent en danger
c'est la seule personne qu'il faut
écouter enfin c'est la mieux placée pour
savoir quel est réellement en danger
trois jours d'audience pour cerner la
personnalité de l'accusé un homme
psychologiquement fragile plusieurs fois
hospitalisé en unité psychiatrique et
angoissé par l'idée de la séparation
selon son avocat le matin même je crois
que le ministre avait annoncé que ça
allait les violences faites aux femmes
et les féminicides allait devenir une
cause nationale donc je suis bon voilà
c'est pas le meilleur jour quoi sortir
dès ce mois-ci recolla les violences
faites aux femmes allaient devenir une
cause nationale deux jours on passe pour
un féminicide s'était pas
c'est pas top voilà ce dont je me
rappelle pour l'ouverture du procès
tout le monde voulait essayer de
comprendre tout le monde voulait savoir
comment cet homme en était arrivé à
mettre le
fin à la vie d'une si jeune femme sans
véritable raison est aussi sauvagement
quand même
vous expliquer comment on en arrive là
pour moi faut pas que les gens aient
pardonne mais quand on la part des gens
les gardent la perpétuité
la prison à vie et tu sais pas s'il faut
pas cette façon ils sont pas
récupérables et c'est donc là on n'est
pas dans ce registre là donc il faut que
ça passe
[Musique]
selon vous ce n'est pas un jaloux
maladie dont absolument pas je j'ai
évacué ça
c'est ce que j'appelle en matière
criminelle un crime de deux propriétés
c'est à dire que c'est on va au delà de
la soumission c'est à dire que tu
m'appartiens
les psys ont bien des crises ambiance
était son trophée est pour rien au monde
ils auraient voulu lâcher son trophée il
n'a jamais montré et s'est jamais excusé
il a jamais montré de remords l'a jamais
dit qu'il aimait et l'aisne
[Musique]
mais il a quand même fallu on en arrive
à l'emprise d'un homme sur une femme est
ce que c'est le scénario inévitable
auquel on ne peut pas échapper c'est
fait c'est la grande question de tous
les féminicides en fait
[Musique]
depuis le décès d'hélène
on a essayé de me remets cache pas les
jets parole aussi avant de monter à
cheval
a continué à monter à cheval
ce que ça a été trop dur pour moi
j'en voulais un peu à tout le monde ne
pas me l'avoir dit qu'à étendre telle
paix est en danger si
j'allais qu'elle est en danger ce jour
là que j'ai vu courir le joueur est
rentré dedans avec mon scooter
n'aurait pas hésité
[Musique]
on
en
moi
[Musique]
à